I'm um if my mother knew I was standing
at the front of a church in front of
hundreds of people she'd have a heart
attack but I I'm very happy to be here I
I would be remiss if I didn't my editor
Bill Phillips is here the one who was
primarily responsible for the success of
my first two books and heavily involved
in the third I want understand and I you
write a book about the collectivity of
achievement you can't but acknowledge
people like Bill I I was going to give
you all a choice I I can either do a
kind of relatively short synopsis of my
book and we can do lots of QA or I can
tell you a story
um which and I thought sorry I didn't
really sort of stack the deck I realize
um so I am a lot of this book is about
culture and about how culture matters
and by but that I mean how does the
where we're from and who our ancestors
were make a difference in how we do our
jobs and how good we are or what we
choose to do for a living and that's a
take that idea takes up a whole second
half of the book and it's a very it's a
very um I think profound and sometimes
difficult thing to wrestle with and so
the one of the examples I use in the
book to illustrate this point of how
much culture matters is plane crashes of
a whole chapter on plane crashes and
sort of thought I do today is tell a
story from that chapter and I will warn
you though that I'm not going to tell
the whole chapter the whole chapter I'm
taking an excerpt out and so what I'm
going to tell you it makes a good deal
less sense then the version you'll read
in the book and it's also a good deal
scarier than the version you're reading
the book but right who in this room will
be flying in a plane in the next month
or so
sorry to hear that
um but I think so you did scary but the
most important thing about this plane
crash though that I want to talk about
is that it's scary not because it is
unusual it is scary because it is
typical which is a very important thing
to keep in mind so anyway here goes um
the crash when I talk about was I was a
was Avianca oh five two which takes off
from Colombia modeun Colombia on January
25th 1990 bound for JFK Airport in New
York and as most of you know Colombia is
not that far from the United States
where it's just on the other side of the
Caribbean Sea and to get up to New York
from Colombia you cross the Caribbean
Sea in the Gulf and you go up the east
coast of the United States but as it
happens this was January and there was a
nor'easter along the East Coast and all
kinds of planes were delayed that night
among them Avianca o52 so here they were
on a relatively routine flight from
Columbia to New York the captain of the
of the plane was a man named Laurie on
Oh kevie ettus and the copilot was a man
named Richie Oh clots so caveat and
clots are flying this plane and they
start to get held up by air traffic
control and they are held up because the
weather is so bad very very thick fog
and high winds they're held up first
above Norfolk Virginia for about 20
minutes
and then above Atlantic City for 30
minutes and then again outside of JFK
about 40 miles outside of JFK for an
additional 30 minutes so after about an
hour and a quarter of delay and they're
cleared for landing and they come down
into the runway at JFK and they
encounter a really severe wind shear
when they're about 500 feet above the
ground now wind shear as I'm sure most
of you know is a situation where the
wind is very blowing very heavily in the
face of the aircraft and so you add
power to maintain constant speed and
then at a certain point the wind just
drops off boom right all of a sudden
you're going too fast
now normally in that kind of situation
what happens in a plane is that the
autopilot will
and you'll be able to land safely anyway
but as it happens the autopilot for
reasons we don't understand was turned
off on a Bianca o52 possibly because it
was malfunctioning
and so the pilots executed what's called
a go-around which is simply when you're
coming into land and you realize you
can't make the runway so you pull up and
you circle around and they made a big
circle over Long Island and they
reappropriation landing the engineer the
flight engineer cries out flame out on
engine number four right engine and then
flame out on an engine number three one
by one the engines were just blowing
right and the captain says at that point
show me the runway because he thinks if
we're close enough to JFK I can guide
this triple plane in for landing and it
won't matter that we're losing all of
our engines but they can't see the
runway because it's fog and also they're
nowhere near JFK there's still 14 miles
away from from from the airport and so
the crash they come down and they
actually crash in the backyard of John
McEnroe's father's estate on oysters Bay
in Long Island and it's 73 people died
and it's one of the worst accidents in
the New York area in many years and the
next day of course the flight
investigators come and they comb through
the wreckage and they retrieve the black
box and they start their investigation
and typically these investigations can
take weeks to uncover the cause of the
crash but in this case it doesn't take
weeks in fact they know by the next
morning what caused the crash of a
Bianca 5 - and it has nothing to do with
the plane the plane was in perfect
working order and has nothing to do with
the pilots they weren't drunk or high or
sick or it was nothing to do in fact
with the weather although the weather
was certainly bad last that night and
had nothing to do with air traffic
control they didn't make any
catastrophic mistakes the cause of the
crash was actually really simple to put
it in the argot of of the aviation world
it was fuel exhaustion they'd run out of
gas now when I said in the beginning
that this was a typical crash I didn't
mean by that that planes run out of fuel
all the time they don't
meant by saying that it was a typical
crash was that it took out the form of I
did not have a catastrophic cause we
often think that accidents like plane
crashes are catastrophes in the sense
that something blows up in the cockpit
and the captain is thrown back against
his seat and he says dear God and the
flight attendant comes rushing in and
her face is ashen in the and in the back
that passengers are screaming that's our
mental image of what a plane crash is
right that's what we've seen in
Hollywood but in fact nothing could be
further from the truth
plane crashes rarely take that form at
all in fact what they tend to be far
more often is a very sort of subtle
process that begins very slowly and
gradually overtakes the pilots until the
plane ends up in some kind of
irredeemable crisis so for example if
you look at lots of plane crashes what
you discover is that overwhelmingly they
happen when the weather is poor now not
when the weather is so terrible that no
plane should be in the sky but just that
the weather is bad enough the pilot is
under some degree of stress you'll also
find the plane crashes invariably
happened when the plane is behind
schedule right not just behind schedule
but enough behind schedule the pilots
are hurrying and we always know we all
know that you start to make mistakes
when you hurry in an overwhelming number
of cases plane crashes happen when the
two pilots have never flown together
before all right so they don't know each
other really well they're not
comfortable with working particularly in
times when when things get difficult
they're not good at working together yet
and we also know that plane crashes are
overwhelmingly associated with errors on
the part of the pilots and not just one
or two errors but a typical plane crash
involves seven consecutive errors each
of which would not be sufficient to
cause an accident but in combination is
enough to bring down the plane and when
you look at those areas what you
discover is that overwhelmingly they are
not examples they're not cases of gross
pilot negligence and they're not
examples it's not like the pilot turns
left and should have turned right or
pulls down on this lever when they
should have pulled up on that waver
rather when you look closely at what
causes those sorts of errors that lead
to a plane crash
they are overwhelmingly errors of
communication one pilot is supposed to
tell the other pilot something and
doesn't or he tells them something and
he doesn't say it in a form that allows
the other pilot to understand right
memens when you look closely at plane
crashes what you discover is that they
are overwhelmingly not technological or
technical phenomenon they are social
phenomena and that's why a Bianca oh
five two is so typical because it is
really the kind of quintessential social
accident one of the things I did when I
was trying to understand this plane
crashes that I hung out with experts on
plane crashes and one of the guys that I
spent time with was this really
marvelous pilot a sri lankan but named
Suren wot wotty and he flies for a very
big airline and he's an expert on what's
called human factors which is that those
are the people who study the interaction
of technology and humans right which is
very much what a plane crash is all
about and he sort of walked me through
that accent and he points out that it is
typical I mean as I described before
what a typical accident was all about
we've got the bad weather here right as
you almost always do got the plane
behind schedule as we almost always have
and I got the the malfunction the minor
malfunction of the of the autopilot
which is a contributing factor not
something that would triple the plane
but just something that adds to the
stress of the pilot but in or what it
also makes the point that one of the
things that's very clear when you look
at that plane crash is how tired the
captain was Kelly Ennis is flying a
Boeing 707 now that was the previous
workhorse that's the predecessor to the
737 which is the current workhorse of
the aviation world but it's a really an
old generation plane and when you when
you pull all of your levers the levers
are actually connected with pulleys to
the sheet metal of the plane it's an
actual he said flying up 707 is like
rowing the boat it's a physical I mean
today you use a little joystick but it's
really easy but it's actually really
hard to fly this thing and here you have
caveat us who is circling around the
East Coast for an hour and a
Corder and it's actually hard work he
starts to get tired if you look in the
cockpit of a 707 you see that the all of
the the the gauges are likely small like
the size of coffee cups
whereas today they're like this big it's
really easy to see them when you're
working hard but in his case it starts
to get really hard because he's has to
splint and to read in all of his various
controls and we know he's tired because
he starts to ask for things to be
repeated over and over again when we
listen to the flight transcript which is
one thing that happens to you when you
start to get exhausted right you can't
process things as easily and quickly as
you could before and he also asked for
things to be translated into Spanish for
him even though he's a fluent English
speaker which is another thing that
happens to us when we get tired we are
kind of peripheral cognitive processes
start to shut down and he also starts to
make mistakes on the first aboard of
landing you have something called a
ground proximity warning system which
tells you if you're coming in too low
and he's coming in too low and the the
ground proximity goes off 15 times some
voice that says you know and he seems to
ignore it as if he's gonna tune dit out
and we also know he's high because he um
he could easily have asked to land at
Philadelphia a good hour before the
crash in New York and doesn't it's as if
he's kind of locked in on New York as
his destination and can't conceive of
changing his plan in any way which is
another another thing that happens to us
when we're when we're exhausted so we
know that's that that's one thing that's
going on that cockpit is we have a tired
pilot but the other thing that um robot
he pointed out was what's strange about
what was going on in that cockpit was
how quiet it is particularly Klotz the
co-pilot
is the pilot who is responsible for all
of the communication with air traffic
control he's the one who's supposed to
be coordinating bringing this plane in
to landing and he seems to be very very
passive in a way that seems very
peculiar so for example he doesn't tell
air-traffic control that they're running
out of fuel until the end of the third
holding pattern which would be unusual
if they are
approaching this kind of crisis and he
does tell them that they immediately say
you know Avianca o52 cleared for landing
but what we think
Klotz thought they were saying was that
he was allowed to go they were allowing
a bianca to go to the front of the line
of all of the planes that were that were
circling around JFK last night laughs at
night he thought they were putting them
at the front of the queue so they could
land first in fact they were putting
them at the end of the queue so they
could land last of all the ones that
were cleared for landing it's a really
crucial misunderstanding and in fact one
that would true fatal for this
particular plane but um plots never once
tries to clarify he never once steps in
with our childhood control and says are
we talking about the front of the line
or the back of the line in fact he
doesn't bring up the subject of fuel
again for another 38 minutes
right and when I was talking about water
he kept coming back to this silence
issue this kind of passivity because he
thought it was really at the root of
trying to understand what went wrong
that night in the cockpit of Avianca who
five-two he tells me this really
fascinating story rot what he does about
what had happened when that day we met
in um at his hotel him an N and they
just flown into JFK that morning and
that afternoon rather and he'd done he
flies those huge air buses and he'd just
come in from Dubai and he was light and
I said well why were you late he said
well because we had this issue just a
couple of hours out of Dubai you know
when you fly from Dubai to New York you
go north right you go up over Moscow on
the Arctic Circle and then you come down
and when they were over Moscow a woman
in the back I'm an Indian woman who was
trapped traveling with elderly anyone
traveling with her husband and had a
stroke and she'd started vomiting and
having seizures and a doctor they found
a doctor he'd gone back and he had said
she only has at best an hour to live we
have to get her medical attention and he
was at that point over Moscow and he had
to make a series of decisions about what
to do in order to say this woman's life
and his first thought was I can't land
in Moscow I mean here's a elderly couple
they have no money they don't even speak
English they're from some little
any village in the Punjab if I if I if I
plunk them down in Moscow they're going
to get eaten alive
he's like we'll never see them again
right so he's like I gotta find a first
world country as exactly Frazee use um I
have to find a first world destination
for this couple and so he thinks
Helsinki right so that's where he's
gonna land a plane and his next problem
is he's heavy he's 60 tons overweight
think about it he just took off from
Dubai planes are not supposed to land
when they have that much fuel right a
plane he's supposed to use up all your
fuel get your destination and then you
land but he's got 60 tons of extra fuel
and the planes electronics are not
calibrated to land a plane that that's
that's that heavy so he has this
decision to make what do I do
do I go over the Baltic Sea and dump my
fuel right they think that'll take 40
minutes and besides no one's very happy
when you dump 60 tons fuel in the middle
of the baltic sea so he thinks okay i'm
gonna land heavy now landing heavy means
that you have to turn off your
electronics and basically land the plane
yourself as light as a feather and if
you don't you could damage you could
structurally damage the plane and these
are planes are for 500 million dollars
each right they're not cheap things it's
huge Airbus so immediately he has to
start dealing with this crisis and he
has a window of 40 minutes right in
which to figure it out so he has to get
on the plant on the on the radio with
his superiors in Dubai and say is it
okay if I land heavy I'm gonna risk your
brand-new for two million dollar plane
but I think I need to write he's got to
get on the phone with Helsinki on the
airport he's never landed at and that he
doesn't even know can handle his plane
and learn everything he can about that
Airport and figure it out as well he
learns when he's talking to them that
typically when you landed Helsinki you
come in over the water not over the city
because they don't want planes coming in
over the city for noise reasons but when
you come in that way over the water
typically the wind is behind you but
well he's heavy
he can't be landing with the wind behind
him he needs to land into the wind so he
has to not only get Helsinki to tell him
about their Airport really fair
I'm into doing what you're not supposed
to do which is coming in over Helsinki
menaced he's got to talk to the doctor
who's tending to the woman the back
exactly how much time do I need right
he's gonna get an ambulance waiting on
the ground ready to right where he's
going to land come in immediately get
that woman off the plane he's gotta get
his flight attendants to to communicate
to the people in the back that no we're
not gonna crash and no this isn't
horrible but we have a woman who's very
sick he's got I could go on but if you
think about all the things he had to do
in order to prepare for that landing
right what that meant was that for that
40 minutes he never stopped talking
talked the entire time right and in fact
what we're talking about when we talk
about what it means to be a good pilot
because he is being a really good pilot
in that moment sure he needs to be able
to land heavy that takes technical
skills but mostly what we are asking of
that pilot in that moment in that crisis
is that he'd be able to communicate
right he'd be able to get on the phone
with his bosses back home and talk them
into letting him land the plane get on
the phone with Helsinki and talk them
into letting him land into the wind get
on the phone with the ambulance guys and
get them all ready get on the radio with
the people in the back and get them all
calm down talk to them on and on and on
we think when we talk about what it
means to be a good pilot that we're
talking about technical skills and
daring do and that laconic voice and
being able to fly a plane through two
canyons and roll the plane when but in
fact that has nothing to do with what it
means to be a good pilot what it means
to be a good pilot is to be able to do
what about what he was doing right which
is to be able to talk to all kinds of
different people in a very open and
honest and persuasive way and talk your
way out of this particular crisis right
so with that in mind let's think about
what was going on in the cockpit of a
Vianca o52 and I'm going to read you now
that transcript a little bit of the
transcript of from the flight recorder
and this is when they're going into JFK
for their first abortive landing okay so
caveat it says
remember they're in heavy fog caveated
says the runway
where is it I don't see it I don't see
it right comes it can't see it and then
the they realize they're not going to be
able to make it and they pull up and
pull up the landing gear and they start
their go-around and the captain asked
Klotz
the copilot to ask air traffic control
for another traffic pattern and ten
seconds pass and caveated says it's like
almost himself in this could mutters to
himself
we don't have fuel right and then
seventeen seconds pass now just to get a
sense of this right we've just come from
hearing this story about a guy who had a
crisis that was this much as serious as
the one that's an Avianca oh five two
and he never stops talking for forty
minutes there's not a moment of silence
in the cockpit of rawat yz-plane right
we just had ten seconds of silence
between captain muttering about we don't
know field and now we have another 17
seconds and we're going to do this do
the 17 seconds just to understand what
this is like ready the plane is you the
thing is on empty right you've just
botched your landing nothing 14 15 16 17
and then caveat a says I don't know what
happened with the runway I didn't see it
now that's in the past
right and they can't move on they're
still kind of thinking about they're not
even thinking about how to land a plane
to think about oh my goodness we botched
the runway right and then Klotz says
finally Klotz the one who's supposed to
be doing the communicating in this in a
situation says I didn't see it the
energy after control comes in and says
tells me to make a left turn and
caveated says to cloths
he says tell them tell air-traffic
control we are in an emergency and then
Klotz says to our traffic control that's
right two one eight zero on the heading
and we'll try again we're running out of
fuel now let's go back to the scene in
the cockpit again remember there
there there they had the fuel gauge on
empty they'd blown their shot at landing
they know that there is a whole long
line of planes in the sky above JFK
waiting to land right there in crisis
mode they're somewhere out over Long
Island and the captain is desperate he
says to Klotz tell them we are in an
emergency right he's panicking at this
point properly and what does clots say
clots says that's right two one eight
zero on the heading and we'll try once
again we're running out of fuel now
first of all that phrase running out of
fuel has no meaning in the world of
aviation by definition as you are coming
into land you're running out of fuel all
planes run out of fuel at the very end
of their journey right it doesn't mean
anything do you hear that if you're an
air traffic controller you it doesn't be
doesn't check any boxes or spark any
special-interest right no and also think
about the structure of that sentence he
starts that critical sentence with the
routine acknowledgment of the
instructions and then in the second half
is where he puts his concern we're in
crisis right it would be as if that's
all wrong right it'd be as if you're in
a restaurant and you say to the waitress
I'll have a refill on that coffee and
I'm choking on a chicken bone what's she
gonna do she's gonna look at you like oh
honey that's not the way we talk when
we're trying to communicate about our
situation
um even the all that he puts between the
two halves of that sentence is really
important right it serves to undercut
the seriousness of what he's saying in
fact later during the inquest that they
brought laboring in the air traffic
controllers who were communicating with
a Bianca o52 that night and they all say
the same thing which was we had no idea
they were in trouble it's like one of
them says it sounded like like Klotz was
totally nonchalant when he was talking
to us there was nothing in his tone of
voice to suggest or the structure of his
speech of his sentences to suggest that
something was seriously amiss with the
plane now there's an actual term that
linguists use to describe what was going
on what plots was doing and it's called
mitigation
my mitigation is the word that we use to
describe situations where where people
undercut the seriousness of what they're
saying and all of us mitigate all the
time right if you're if you want your
boss if you're desperate for your boss
to read something you've written and get
back to you you don't say to your boss
you know I need you to read this now and
get back to me you say you know if you
have time this weekend if you could look
at this it would I mean it's not a big
deal but I just really that's mitigation
right and you do that for a reason if
you said to your boss I need you to read
this now you wouldn't be employed much
longer right it's a very appropriate use
of of in that situation of of this kind
of social tool on for communicating now
no way that's fine but in the aviation
world what people began to realize was
that they began to get obsessive
mitigation because they realized that
this was a cause of a lot of problems in
the cockpit right the cockpit was a
place where mitigation wasn't an
appropriate strategy you let me give you
an example so suppose that you and I are
you're the pilot and I'm the copilot and
we're flying and in along and we see
that on the weather radar we see that
twenty five miles ahead there's a big
ugly patch of thunderstorms right and a
traffic control has been telling us over
the course the last 10 minutes about the
really choppy weather ahead but I
noticed that you you guys are the pilot
that you're just flying straight into it
right you haven't made any attempt to
kind of so what I want to do is to
communicate to you the fact that we
really should find a way of going around
the thunderstorms right so how do I do
it now there are many different
strategies that I could use that differ
in terms of their level of mitigation so
the thing the first thing I could say to
you which is zero mitigation would be a
a command I could say something like
turn thirty degrees right right it's
command now that is wholly inappropriate
for me to say that to really hard for me
instead because what I'm saying is
I'm the boss not you and I'm saying
you're not a good pilot right which is a
hard thing to say to someone who is your
superior in that notion so maybe I want
to cut it down just a little bit so I
could make what they call a crew
obligation statement which I could say
something like I think we need to
deviate right around now that's softer I
think and I use we and instead of saying
30 degrees I just say deviate right
around now right a little more
a little more acceptable for me to put
it that way but that might also be too
much so I could take it down one more
notch and I could use a suggestion I
could say let's go around the weather my
furnace together to you name this mine
is playing let's just go around right
that's a little softer but maybe they
even that's too hard so what if I could
I could just do a simple question I
could just say um which direction do you
want to deviate right just assume I'm
assuming you gonna deviate sooner or
later you just are you gonna go right or
left
right let's go old more so now maybe
even that's just wrong maybe I wanted to
simply state a preference like ah you
know if it was up to me I'd go I'd go
left right it's even softer and softest
of all would be the hint I could just
say boy looks mean up there yeah there
is a world of difference between turn
thirty degrees right and boy it looks
mean up there ahead right world of
difference in one case I command an
action a response from you and the last
case I give you something so soft
that's easy for you to ignore it right
well this was what people in the
aviation world became why people in the
aviation world became obsessed with
mitigation because when they started to
listen to and the transcripts of those
black boxes what they begun to
understand is that in the minutes and
hours before plane crashes what you saw
was lots and lots of mitigation right
that's what was going on in the cockpit
that was causing all of those errors was
people were too often relying on hints
and too infrequently using the kind of
language that would compel
action so for example is a famous crash
on air Florida crash in the 1980s in
Washington and it's a was one of those
wintry days and it was sleeping and all
the planes you know how you get de-iced
will the plane got D ice but it was they
were taking off at rush hour you know
how they'll have a line of like 15
planes in a row and this one was number
15
so the bhindi ice and they're creeping
forward you know and the sleep comes
down and the ice begins to reform on the
wings so what happens is the copilot who
is has flown in bad weather quite a lot
wants to tell the pilot that this is not
good we have to get D iced again right
so what does he say well he says uh he
hints he says the first thing he says is
look how the ice is just hanging on this
back there back there see that right so
he says tip total mitigation just
throwing it out there look at that right
ice he's hoping that the captain kind of
fills in the blanks and doesn't work and
they're starting to creep forward right
they're no longer 15s for takeoff
they're now nine three takeoff and the
ice is getting a little bit thicker so
he tries again he says see all those
icicles on the back there and everything
now he's like icicles right it's like
he's trying to ramp it up a little bit
but it's still just a hint right just
seals icicles let me Adam just making
conversation up there in the cockpit
nothing happens couple more minutes past
now they've crept up a little closer
they're like fifth for takeoff
right now the copilot is getting a
little bit concerned
so what's he say he says boy this is a
this is a losing battle you're trying to
di snows things it gives you a false
sense of security that's all that does
right still ahead look strong little
like three sentences of hints but it
still hits right nothing happens pilots
ignoring him they've not crept up there
like number two for takeoff and he's
starting to get really really worried so
what does he do he upgrades he goes from
a hint to a suggestion the action
suggestin actually says let's check
those tops again since we've been
sitting here a while
he's not only suggesting action finally
the captain responds and says no I think
we get to go here in a minute
just wants to take off right so I get up
for first in line' in line for landing
and on the runway first in line for
takeoff and they take off south up on
the South runway it had had wash and
Reagan as you know if you know this that
when ice forms on your wings it
diminishes your lift right the planes
ability to take off when it's really
really heavy and take off so they take
off and then they can't make it starts
to go down like this and the Potomac is
right bellowing they clipped the 14th
Street bridge and as they're going down
the copilot turns to the captain and
they have the first moment of honest
conversation honest open communication
since the two of them got into the
cockpit and the captain the co-pilot
says Larry
we're going down Larry and the captain
says I know it right and thank Rogers
now fighting mitigation has become one
of the great Crusades in the airline
world in fact when you look at why plane
crashes have dropped so dramatically
over the last 20 years
it is principally because of the success
in retraining pilots in how they talk
right how they talk to each other for
example this was never the case before
but now very often cope our pilots are
required to call each other by their
first names and the idea is if you're
talking to someone you're not calling
someone Captain Smith but rather calling
him Jack you're more likely to
communicate openly with him sometimes
some
airlines have done away with captain and
first officer or pilot and co-pilot
entirely and they just talk about the
flying pilot and the non flying pilot
again it's an attempt to foster some
kind of openness in communication they
also give pilot scripts now you know how
it at you know Brown places like that
they give you they give freshmen boys
all those instructions about how to make
out with a girl Jean about this I'm sure
you do
you know like can I place my hand here
yes or no can I move my hand six inches
lower is that a yes will you sign here
that guy said they they do that with
captain's they give you scripts and if
you're if you're a co-pilot you're
having a trouble communicating with your
captain you take out the script and they
you just weaned off the things and it's
surprisingly effective in in creating
more open conversation in times where
the social context makes open
communication I'm difficult right this
has actually been one of the great
success stories in the world of aviation
okay so let's go back to a v2 Avianca
and let's think about what was going on
in that [ __ ] but in terms of mitigation
right so they've just blown the first
landing and they're circling around over
Long Island and Klotz is on the phone
with our traffic control and he's trying
to figure out when they can land again
like the critical question and caveat is
turns to him and he says What did he say
meaning what did air traffic control
just tell you and clot says I already
advised him that we are going to attempt
again because now we can't and then he
just his voice chills off and four
seconds of sounds right and then
caveated says advise him we are in an
emergency the second time he said dead
four more seconds pass
captain tries again he says did you tell
him right and Claude says yes sir I
already advised him and then clots
starts talking Derek traffic control
he's going over really routine details
and I air traffic control I says here
Jeff control one five zero maintaining
2000 Evian cos zero five too heavy and
the captain starts to freak out he says
advise him we don't have fuel so clots
gets back on the radio with air traffic
control and he says climb and maintain
3000 and we're running out of fuel sir
right there is again does not mention
the word emergency no emergency if you
are an air traffic controller that is
the word you are trained to listen for
right the minute someone says emergency
you act does Klotz use it no he just
says we're running out of fuel which by
the way every single plane in the air
that night over JFK was also doing right
and when does he say that phrase running
out of fuel once again in the second
half of the sentence preceded by the
mitigating ah right
he's mitigating now a minute passes a
minute an air traffic control says and
evie anka zero five too heavy ah I'm
going to bring you about 15 miles
northeast and then turn you back into
the approach is that okay with you and
your fuel and clot says I guess so thank
you very much right I guess so
thank you very much about to crash now
what's going on here why you see this
way
well one key fact is there Kennedy and
one thing you have to know about Kennedy
is that air traffic control at Kennedy
is famous throughout the aviation world
these are possibly the finest air
traffic controllers in the world they
have run one of the busiest airports in
the world with an extraordinary safety
record over the last 50 years they are
also the most obnoxious air traffic
controllers in the world they are famous
they are bullies they won't put up with
anything right as if there's a pilot's
have all kinds of great stories and if
you ask them to tell you JFK stories are
just an endless number
and I'm what I heard was uh you know JFK
is so uh crazy that I'm so large that
it's once--you'll and it's really easy
to get lost so there was a pilot once
and he's he gets lost and he's trying to
find his way to the terminal and he's on
so he's like he's just bothering the
air-traffic controller so much for
directions and finally she turns to him
and she says on the radio and the course
you know all the pilots are listening in
right um so the air traffic controller
turns to him and she says um shut up
stay there don't move
I'll get back in touch with him right
when I'm ready right and there's silence
and the pilot says ma'am was I'm married
to you in an earlier life so here we
have
so these guys are you know this is what
they're like right there
total bullies they push you around and
the only way to get what you want if
you're trying to land at Kennedy is to
push back right you've got to play their
game and they will only respect you if
you're willing to stand up to them and
say look this is my issue right I needed
to be resolved right now and then
they'll then they'll respond and that's
what plots can't do he's intimidated
that's what's going on here
I guess so thank you very much and
that's what's so puzzling about this
because we can understand intimidation
and mitigation when what you're trying
to do is avoid a thunderstorm 25 miles
ahead right you're going to survive the
thunderstorm we can even kind of
understand it when we're in that plane
on the ground at wash and national
because it is possible it's a judgment
call about whether you want to get D
iced right it's not a sure thing the
plans not going to make it and he was
just kind of worried and one guy had a
risk threshold that was a little bit
higher than the other it is really hard
to understand mitigation when you're in
a plane and your fuel gauge is on empty
and you know you're going to crash right
unless you do something now so that's
the puzzle why is Klotz that way under
this most dire of circumstances so the
answer I think or one of the answers one
one useful way of thinking about this is
to use the work of this really
fascinating Dutch psychologist named
Gert of steady and he works he's a guy
who works for IBM in the 60s and when
IBM was this sort of Colossus you know
multinational all over the globe and
what HOF City does is he goes around the
world and he gives people and every one
of the IBM offices a very detailed
psychological questionnaire because he's
trying to answer the question of how
should we behave as a company
differently in different cultures you
know do we do we run IBM the same way in
Cape Town as we do in Copenhagen right
that's what he's trying to figure out
and so he's dispatched by the company to
go and sort of try and get a read on
what it means to belong to a particular
local culture and he organizes this in
Armus database and comes up with a set
of what are called Hoffs teenies
dimensions which are now famous in the
world of cross-cultural psychology there
are ways of understanding the different
the ways in which the world the cultures
of the world differ right so he comes up
with a series of dimensions continuum
that he says are the easiest way to
categorize differences among cultures so
one of them for example is individualism
collectivism right and he says all of
the countries of the world exists
somewhere along this continuum so for
example the most collectivistic culture
in the world according to Huff's TD is
Guatemala the most individualistic
culture in the world according to F CD
is the United States right which makes
sense why are we the only industrialized
nation in the world not to have national
health insurance because we are
individual one of the definitions of
individualism is to what extent do you
have do you feel responsible for the
welfare of someone other than yourself
right that's the definition and we feel
less responsible for the welfare of
people other than ourselves than any
other country in the world makes sense
that fits with her another one of his
dimensions is uncertainty avoidance
which is how tolerant is a culture of
ambiguity you know when things go hairy
and there's a big crisis do you are you
willing to be flexible or do you adhere
to the rules to the kind of principles
that you laid they laid down beforehand
and what he finds again once again is
that there's wide differences among
cultures along that dimension so the
countries of the world who are the least
tolerant of ambiguity who are the least
most willing most most keen on sticking
to the rules regardless of circumstance
are Greece Portugal Guatemala Uruguay
and Belgium right the five countries of
the world at the other end of the
spectrum the most tolerant of ambiguity
are Hong Kong Sweden Denmark Singapore
and then the last will come as no
surprise
to me since my family's from there
Jamaica um now it's really important to
understand that Hough city is not making
a value judgment here right he's not
saying it's better to be here on the
continuum than there he's just saying
look this is just one of the ways in
which cultures differ and it's a way to
for us to understand when we're dealing
with that culture um what their what
their frame of reference is right and
he's saying that look that these things
are also pretty specific the cultures
have dramatic differences along these
lines right so when we look at that list
of five you can see that Belgium is one
of the least tolerant of ambiguity and
Denmark is one of the most tolerant of
ambiguity
well Belgium and Denmark are two
northern European countries that are
pretty close together that'd be roughly
the same food that have architecture
that's kind of the same that had been
democratic for an awful long time that
you would think as a stranger going in I
must be pretty similar in culture along
these cultural dimensions and hostility
is saying no they're actually profoundly
different that on this dimension Denmark
has more in common with Jamaica and
Belgium has more in common with
Guatemala that's really an interesting a
fascinating insight now of all of
hostilities dimensions though the most
interesting and crucial for our purposes
is something he calls power distance and
power distance is a measure of a
country's orientation towards hierarchy
right and he measures power distance by
asking questions like how likely in in
your culture is it for a superior to
express disagreement with firsta Borden
to express disagreement with a superior
right how much do you guys in your
culture respect this how much do you
venerate somebody or hold someone up
because they are older or um have more
have more experience or are of higher
social standing how common is it how
important is it for people in positions
of power to downplay or accentuate the
difference in their status in the status
of everybody else and he says look
there's huge differences so for example
he says in you
power distance countries you see
political leaders very consciously
trying to to hide their power so he says
if you go to Austria for example very
low power distance country you can see
he would say I got Austrian I would see
the Prime Minister of Austria taking a
streetcar to work that's what you do in
a low power distance culture right he
said also I would you said he would go
to a he was once on holiday in Spain and
he saw the Prime Minister of of the
Netherlands in a in I got one of those
vacation trailer parks right it's like
that's the Netherlands is one of the
lowest power distance countries in the
world that's what you do if you're the
prime minister of the Netherlands you
try to act like as normal a person as
you possibly can they says you know
compare this to France is a very very
high power distance culture he says what
are the odds you would ever see the
president of France in a trailer park in
Spain right zero it's not going to
happen that's up and that's a profound
difference between two countries that by
the way are right next door to each
other right so now when people in the
aviation world hear about power distance
their eyes go wide because they say you
know what that's exactly what we've been
talking about right we are concerned
with nothing more than the issue of the
likelihood of a subordinate expressing
disagreement with a superior right so
they suddenly realize ah this completely
helps us to understand how to under to
understand and to combat plane crashes
this concept they realized says that ena
culture that has a high power distance
right in a culture that respects
hierarchy the task of combating
mitigation will be a lot harder and
similar in fact they say look it should
be possible in fact to understand the
likelihood of a cultures having a plane
crash just by looking at the level of
that cultures power distance and in fact
is a very famous paper done in the 1980s
where they simply list all of the
countries of the world according to
their plane crashes per capita and they
list all of the countries of the world
according to the power distance of their
pilots and they discover that the two
lists are basically the same but this is
the most powerful way to understand the
likelihood of a particular airline
having a crash right so which countries
have the lowest power distance and the
lowest plane crashes per capita well the
countries that you would expect right we
already talked about Austria the United
States very low power distance Australia
classic low power distance Israel right
one of the most low powers and places on
earth can you imagine an Israeli having
diffident and is really subordinate
having difficulty expressing
disagreement who's superior right
in fact parent that parenthetically
somebody was telling me that one of the
big problems with Israeli army patrols
on the West Bank where they're going and
very stealthily at night is that the
leader of the patrol just can't get the
people who are supposed to be his
subordinates to shut up because there's
a constant like no no let's not go that
way no no way so that's you know and one
of the countries that have what is one
of the countries that has one of the
highest levels of power distance in the
world Columbia right in fact the Kennedy
crash is not the first time that Avianca
the national airline of Columbia has had
this particular kind of accident in fact
after that crash they have a kind of
investigation and they go over the fact
that they've had that they had four
crashes in quick succession in that
period all of which took exactly the
same form these were crashes where the
plane was in perfect working order where
the pilots weren't sick or would where
where there wasn't some massive mistake
from air traffic control where there
wasn't some massive technological
failure but still the planes crashed why
because there was a social breakdown
between the pilot and the copilot in
fact there was a crash in in in Madrid
and I'll just quote to you the two lines
from the invent from the conclusion of
the crash from the from the report on
the crash and it was this case of of the
copilot saw something and tried to bring
it to the attention of the pilot and
failed and they the the report said the
copilot was right but they died the
plane crashed because when the copilot
asked questions his implied suggestions
were very
week the captain's reply was to ignore
him totally this was a kind of endemic
problem at a Bianca the problem
that night in other words in that
cockpit was not merely one of clots his
inability to communicate effectively
with caveat Asst it was a problem about
a Bianca's problem of the inability of
co-pilots to communicate with paths and
even more than that it was a symptom of
a cultures inability to allow
subordinates to openly question their
superiors right this can this plane
crash cannot be understood just
individually it has to be understood as
part of a much larger cultural context
now it is very easy I think to find this
kind of talk offensive we don't like to
talk about cultures having traits like
this we find that kind of language and
that line of argument to be problematic
I'm with good reason because so often I
think that kind of a cultural
stereotyping is used to harm but one of
the arguments I make in this book I hope
persuasively is that there are times and
occasions where we have to talk about
cultures in that way because cultures
play such an important role in how we
behave and how we think and how we go
about doing our jobs but if we want to
make people better at those kinds of
things we have to be willing and honest
enough to confront our cultural legacies
and say this is an area where my culture
does not do a good job and this is an
area where my culture does do a good job
right unless we're willing to have that
kind of conversation I think that we
leave all kinds of problems on the table
so back to clots I'm you have to
understand ways from you have to
understand if you want to understand
what happened to that that plane that
night that he comes from a culture that
is deeply hierarchical where it is very
difficult for a subordinate to speak
openly to I'm a superior right where
leaders are supposed to lead and what's
going on that night in the plane his
leader isn't leading Connie Otis the man
who's supposed to be in charge of this
plane is exhausted right he can barely
listen or hearing it yes everything has
to be repeated to him his
at the IDI end of his tether he's been
rowing this boat around the sky for an
hour and a half so clots is all by
himself
right and then he's dealing with the
Kennedy controllers and what do they
like they are these totally low power
distance obnoxious bullying New Yorkers
and he's trying to tell them that he's
in trouble but he's using his own
cultural language right the kind of
language that says when you try and say
that kind of thing you mitigate but who
are these controllers right they come
from a completely different cultural
context and when they hear someone
mitigate they don't think that person is
being appropriately deferential to
Authority they think that person doesn't
have a problem so this is incredible
moment in that in the transcript where
the kind of cultural disconnect between
between the between clots and the and
the air traffic controllers gets so
stark that it's almost painful to read
it's the last exchange between Avianca
and air traffic control and it's just
the crash is minutes away and potts has
just said I guess so thank you very much
right in response to the controllers
question about their full fuel state and
caveat Asst turns the clots and he says
What did he say
meaning what did the controller just
tell you right now I understand again
they are this is at the very very end of
the flight and they are in this boggy
windy night and they're somewhere out
over Long Island and the the fuel gauge
is at empty and one of the flight
attendants who actually we know the
story because she survived one of the
few survivors comes into the cockpit at
that moment to ask what's going on and
she asked the flight engineer and he
just goes like this right they know that
it's kind of over and then there's clots
right and he's absolutely at wit's end
because he has been trying using his own
cultural language to communicate the
seriousness of the plane state to air
traffic control and he realizes he has
completely failed right he's just
completely failed
and the only way that he can make sense
of that the only way it can make sense
of his failure is to assume that he has
somehow offended air-traffic control so
caveated says to him What did he say
what did the air traffic controller say
and claude says in this little small
voice he says the guy is angry and then
the flight engineer says flame out on
engine number four right and then
caveated says where is the runway
because he thinks maybe he can bring the
plane in to land but he can't because
they're miles and miles away and on the
flight transcript after that there's two
minutes of nothing but static and the
last thing you hear is air traffic
control comes on and says hey Bianca oh
five - do you have enough fuel to make
the runway
I think we have time for a few questions
unless I've spooked you all as the uh-oh
there's the mic right um this is back to
outliers just a question about that I
was just curious um in the book where
you talk about the 10,000 hours of
eating practice and I know you don't
call yourself an outlier but I think all
of us would say you're extremely
successful and I was just wondering what
are some of the cultural background that
you would say contributed to your
success or how would you answer that
this is for those who haven't read the
book there's a section in the book where
I talk about what it takes to be good at
something and how there's something
psychologists have sort of come up with
this idea that in an incredibly large
number of cases it seems like in order
to master a complex task you need to
practice for about 10,000 hours which is
four hours a day for 10 years so the
question was did do I have such a 10,000
hour actually besides that so outside of
that that's out of that oh dear um I'm
not very good at answering a lot of
biographical questions but um did I have
a cultural [ __ ] well I mean I grew up in
a in a house where um I realized I guess
the in retrospect of my parents are
borderline workaholics but that was
seemed like a really good thing so maybe
being being growing up in an atmosphere
that venerated work in that way I was it
was important but thank you very much
so one of the examples you use in your
book of people who practiced well was my
favorite rock band The Beatles and I'm
just curious
I understand how their practice in
Hamburg increased their technical skills
but it strikes me their long-term
success was more from their ability to
innovate in a sustained way and this
wondering do you think that came from
practice or something else yes oh this
is a reference along the same lines I
talk about the Beatles and how before
they come to America they have this
extraordinary sojourn in Hamburg where
they are Germany whether the house band
in a strip club and they play eight-hour
sets seven days a week for months of
stretch and that's really where they get
their 10,000 hours in and so the
question was to what extent can we
credit that apprenticeship for their
ability to innovate I think you can
credit a lot you know what innovation is
is is innovation comes when you have
mastered a particular field well enough
to be able to understand all of its
possibilities right it's very difficult
to innovate when you when you don't know
what to innovate but what you don't know
you know what's wrong with the existing
paradigm and they are as rock bands go a
profoundly well educated rock band
because of their I mean they had played
together 1200 times by the time they
come to America you know you you would
be hard-pressed to find a band today at
that age that is paid together half that
many times
Plato live performed live 1200 times by
the time they're in there very early 20s
that's installing and I think that it's
much easier to see to understand how to
innovate when you're you've got that
kind of background you know
I recently discovered and started
devouring the podcasts on the Ted
website and you know immediately when
you see you want to become part of the
event but what I slowly started to
realize is that it's probably easier to
get invited to speak than it is to get a
ticket in the audience and especially
with a ten year waiting list it you know
on the premise we could spend 10,000
hours and yeah you know perfects a skill
and then get invited so I was just
curious if you had any tips on how to
convince the members of Ted to invite
you to the talk yeah I haven't even been
invited back since it is that so I'm I'm
you know I'm a dime on the same
predicament as you are so if I if I hear
anything from them I'll be sure to pass
along but I really enjoy your books and
I hope you keep writing them my question
is about women or actually the lack of
them in kind of the first half of
outliers when you profile both
individuals and groups of people who
have had success they're all male
examples which is not surprising because
of those who have had access to success
in our society etc and the notable
exception is Morita at Kipp Academy
who's a student and whose success may be
before her so when you talk about kind
of the ideal year for a male who wants
to earn a fortune in America to be
warned being 1835 do you think that the
age of the woman is before us and is
that you're in our decade is it ahead of
us what do you think about female
success yeah yeah I mean you're
absolutely right there is an absence of
women in the first half of this book and
it would have been dishonest to put them
in write in my whole argument in the
book is that success is a function of
opportunities that have been that are
granted by society and we have as you
point out over the last you know going
back as long as it's been human history
hugely disproportionately granted those
opportunities to men and I think one of
the ways we we glide we glossed over
that fact is by when we tell stories
about success pretending there's as many
women out there as
there aren't because we just haven't you
know success is not a matt is not a
simple function of people's ability it's
a function of ability plus these but do
I think that will change I certainly
hope so
when I certainly hope if I were to write
another version of this book in 40 years
god forbid I would you would tell a very
different story
but I mean you know when I was it's so
interesting you know I tell the story of
you know Jewish lawyers in New York for
example their rise
well you can't find any in that cohort
there are no women I'm instead of
amazing like their hair was this this
this group beautifully poised to take on
a profession for reasons that I
explained and yet all of those
opportunities were granted to 50% of the
of the group's population I mean it's
sort of like it's that what it is is a
kind of reminder of how tragically we
have under eye under you under utilize
the talents of our population even Bill
Gates school it's an all-boys school I
looked that up I was curious about it so
it's the same thing yeah thank you
hello so I haven't read your most recent
book yet so you might have already
answered this question but um there's a
theorist named Robert Traverse who
writes a lot about a self-deception I
think he actually cited the same story
about the guys with the de-icing on
their wings and his idea is that we can
deceive ourselves into believing that
everything is ok when it's not so I was
wondering if that if you think that
concept works with your cultural ideas
about how people can deceive themselves
into taking off then crashing yeah well
yeah so it is to apply that to this what
I'm talking about
maybe what is part of what's happening
in a high power distance culture is part
of the deception is that the hierarchy
will take care of you
the hierarchy knows more like the person
higher up the chain knows more than you
and so you don't have to assert yourself
in that way whereas the assumption in
the low power distance cultures is that
being higher in the ladder is actually a
more random fact than a fact that speaks
to a meaningful difference in in ability
or judgment so there's that element of
raps there's an additional element of
selfless in high power distance worlds
that being said you know it is important
to point out that a high power distance
is not always a bad thing like a lot of
my that chapter is of my book is
concerned with Korea which is a very
very very high power distance culture
but you can make and which has had all
kinds of consequences for Korean
aviation that really struggle with this
issue in the air but in all kinds of
other areas of Korean life the high
power distance notion has been enormous
ly useful I mean a country does not go
from being in ruins at the end of the
Korean War to being one of the most
powerful economic forces in the world in
a space of half a century unless it has
cultural ideas that support that this
enormous organization and effort and I'm
an order so those you know it's it's
it's um
so I hesitate to kind of
described as we described hierarchy
entirely in negative terms I think could
be a wonderful thing just not in a
carpet it seems that that a lot of what
you're talking about here are things
that are out of people's control the the
role the luck plays in success the
culture we come from and the what we've
been raised with where we're at given
that the other factor the amount of
practice we have to work on our
abilities is something that we can
choose to engage with are there any any
prescriptions is there anything we can
choose to do to deal with the culture
that we come from and how it interacts
with other cultures so this is a good
question um and to my annoyance some
reviewers of my book have accused me of
being a cultural determinist in fact I'm
the opposite so the culture that we come
from is only deterministic of our
behavior if we choose to ignore it right
if you never address so that the chapter
that I was talking about in that in my
talk the plane crash chapter it's really
about Korean air and how Korean air goes
from being an airline that almost gets
pushed out of business because it has so
many plane crashes to being one of them
now what is now today one of the premier
airlines in the world and they transform
themselves in the last 10 years
precisely because they say they decide
at long last to confront their cultural
legacy and deal with it and what they
discover is if they are honest and open
about the fact that in this particular
instance the cockpit being acting like
you're a Korean is not a good idea then
you can change it and they do they take
that airline from literally it was this
close to being to not existing anymore
and it is now an absolutely world-class
airline and what they what they showed
and I continue this theme in the second
half of the book is once we can talk
about and confront culture we can change
culture we're not prisoners of it we're
only prisoners of it if we pretend it
doesn't exist and this is my great
objection to the way we deal with
so-called cultural stereotypes in this
that we are we have decided that it is
always better to ignore them in the
interest of avoiding those few cases
where they are misused and that's a
shame because I for example have another
chapter in the book which talks about
math learning math and points out that
Asian school children vastly
outperformed their Western counterparts
at math right so the question and now
flip the question if they can learn from
us about flying planes can we learn from
them about doing math and the answer is
yes we can and in fact our culture is
Western culture is sorely deficient when
it comes to giving kids the emotional
equipment necessary to achieve at high
school calculus we do a terrible job of
it and they do a really good job of it
and we can does that mean that we are
prisoners of that notion here in the
West No if I could talk about house
there are schools the Kipp schools which
many of you will be familiar with these
charter school movement Kipp Academy is
essentially just an attempt to set up an
Asian school in the middle of the inner
city so it is it's like can we get uh
you know disadvantaged Hispanic and
african-american kids to behave like
Korean school children when they do math
the answer is yes you can it's not that
hard you just you have to be determined
about it and honest about it and say we
haven't prepared these kids culturally
properly for what they're doing so what
I would like to do is I think that we
should look upon cultural legacies is a
big smorgasbord and we should just say
look you know these people do this well
and these people do this well and let's
just have a one let's just let's assume
that everyone has something to teach us
and and that way we can get around the
trap of assuming that um that there is a
kind of a hierarchy of of cultures or
one